تاثيرات وباقي كورونا تتعدى كونها الصحيه
او اقتصاديه فالمصابون به يعانون تداعيات
بعيده المدى ذات تاثيرات المباشره على
الادمغه مجله الطب النفسيه البيولوجي نشرت
دراسه توضح ان الاجهاد الناجم عن جائعه
كورونا ربما تسبب بتقدم عمر ادمغه
المراهقين قبل الاوان بثلاثه اعوام في
الحد الادنى مع تكوينهم تحديات صحيه
سلوكيه مقلقه
في منطقتين من الدماغ تتحكمان بالوصول الى
الذكريات وتنظمان العواطف من ضمنها التوتر
والقلق عبر مقارنه نحو 163 عمليه تصوير
بالرنين المغناطيسي لادمغه مراهقين ثم اخذ
نصفيها قبل الوباء والنصف الاخر
مجموعهما بعد علامات متسارعه للشيخوخه
تظهر بشكل شائع اطفال الذين يعانون العنف
والاهمال فقد يكونوا دماغ فتاه تبلغ من
العمر 16 عاما معادلا لدماغ فتاه تبلغ من
العمر 19 او 20 عاما قبل الجائحه في ما
كان الشباب اكثر عرضه للقلق الشديد
والاكتئاب ومشاكل الصحه العقليه خاصه لما
بعد التاثر بصدمه التجربه
خطوره هذه الدراسه
لا يعلمون اذا كانت هذه التغيرات في
الدماغ دائمه او يمكن تخطيها
لكنهم نصحوا بان يحصل المراهق المتعافي من
قرون على رعايه صحيه جيده وانفتاح على
العلاج وتوافر علاج سلوكيين ونفسي الخاص